[Music]
all right now we're going to talk about
that guy
that that [ __ ] the bitcoin guy bitcoin
guy
yeah he doesn't remember his password
and there's about 220 million dollars
worth of bitcoin 120 million
yeah so it's 7 000 to 7 000
generally 10 years ago
how much did he spend on it it was given
to him
yeah yeah it was gifted yeah oh then
what are you crying about
well it was nothing to them at the time
they were just like hey here's a tip you
wrote a cool blog or whatever
he did some animated thank you from
bitcoin there's nothing out of pocket
you know what i mean it's a gift
but he but but at the time he's just
like whatever
and that's what's so funny about it that
is so ouch
ouch 220 million though big lesson
to learn it's also a huge
uh thing that people don't understand
that there's bitcoins more rare than
people even know right now because of
how much is locked up
billions is locked up in all these walls
that nobody can get into exactly so
there are
18.5 million bitcoin in existence
in existence okay around 20 currently
worth about 140 billion dollars
is lost or stranded or locked out or
whatever
on a cell phone in a teenager's bank
exactly like like
yeah cell phone it makes no [ __ ]
sense i love it so these are
going to have i'm going to have you link
up with my mom i'll call i'll talk to
your mom
i'll talk to your mom are these just all
boomers that have
bitcoin that just have no access to well
this particular guy he is
so his name is stefan thomas a
german-born
programmer living in san francisco and
he has just two guesses left right to
figure out his passport
password for his hard drive
and um in terms of his age i'm not sure
exactly how
wait so he locked his hard drive that
had
yeah so did he act like his like
back then because how did that work yeah
yeah so his private key is his
locked up uh he doesn't know what he
doesn't know where it is
can he get like a hacker so what happens
if you can't if you if you have your
last two tries on the hard drive and
it's wrong it's iced out forever
that's how it works is the way that he
set it up there's actually some where if
people are really protective there are
some hard drives that you can get
they're actually self confused on the
inside so they actually like burn the
chips
like submission impossible [ __ ] yeah so
they actually do have some like i don't
know if this one's like that but
they are something that you can buy yeah
does it shh like rinse that does it ch
yeah if you smoke but then you can't see
it you have to put it
in front of a mirror that's like setting
up booby traps and then you forgot there
were booby traps and then you [ __ ]
hurt yourself
yeah that's basically what this guy but
at the time he thought it was so sick
but then he also didn't think it was
that
interesting either it's so weird yeah
it's really interesting yeah because
exactly he was gifted this these
bitcoins
because he created an animation like
pretty much educating people on what
bitcoin is
there was like yeah he helped it grow
like he he's one of the helpers for why
it rose in pisces exactly
and then he doesn't [ __ ] he can't
reap that oh my god
he lost interest he made the maymays
he's so sad can't like mark zuckerberg
help him or something this is back in
2011 when he got
gifted this this amount of bitcoin wow
yeah it's pretty crazy and then there's
this other dude
who he threw away the hard drive
where he had a big point yeah there are
some of these guys who are like
going to the the the landfills and
digging
for days and days because it's like they
have millions of dollars worth yeah so
they're like even if they spend like
a year looking through it and they find
it it's worth it they change their life
if they can recover it i've had a hard
drive that was unrecoverable before like
where i took it to like three guys and
they're all like
oh i still got hard drives
what so back then you you would store
bitcoin on a hard drive
because there was nowhere else to put it
didn't have all these like places where
you can go now like you can go to a coin
base or you can go to like a gemini and
you can set up a wallet and like store
your [ __ ] there
back then they didn't have all that so
you had to store it on the blockchain
itself
and so you had to protect it with a
private key the entire
entire thing on there i was listening to
a planet money episode recently on there
there was a guy he didn't have a lot he
only had like maybe four of them
or something in his attic at home yeah
but it was like you know not millions
and uh they were like
okay can you keep us on the phone with
you while you like look around in your
your attic or whatever and he finds his
hard drive
and he he spends hours he's on hours on
the phone with that
the reporter so they can record it for
the story and then he spends hours
getting it he finally
opens it and he has to download the
entire you know the entire chain so you
see what it is and how much money it is
so that was the wrong one and it was
like we just spent hours listening to
this episode of a guy who just
didn't even find his money oh no but
you're on the edge of your seat i bet
i was you listened for hours no no no i
mean they cut it down for the episode
for like minutes but it was just like
but that's the thing about it so back
then yeah you had to download
all of it and well even now sometimes
you still have to do that which is why
some ethereum applications exist that
let you
target specific um things in the
blockchain so you have to download the
whole [ __ ] thing
at one point um like this is a cool one
called grt that's doing that right now
where you just selectively drop in and
you can program
based on specific moments of blockchain
but
yeah it's super cool all this shit's so
cool how do you even learn all this
i just read all the boards about all
this stuff and right on the boards
don't go to coin telegraph though if you
want to learn about crypt though
that place exists to uh
shill or fud crypto based on how they
want to buy or sell it like they just
there was an article that got released
this morning that said that bitcoin had
a double spend and so bitcoin just
dropped in price because all these
[ __ ] normies bought bitcoin and they
all
are like i don't know what that means
that sounds bad and so they're selling
it but there was no double spend
and it was just completely fake news
[ __ ] and so
um by the time that all the bitcoin
community was able to say there's no
double spend this [ __ ] would be
worthless right now
because a double spend means you're able
to send your money
out somewhere and then um
you basically can just send it again
because
it takes a certain amount of time for
the block to confirm that you sent the
money
and so you can basically double spend
your coins
by just taking advantage of the
confirmation delay
and so everybody started going holy [ __ ]
if you could do that
i could [ __ ] make bitcoin like as
many bitcoins as i want i just keep on
do taking advantage of that delay and so
that would make bitcoin worthless like
instantaneously that's not what happened
it never happened it's just normies who
so coin
telegraph does that all the time they're
a horrible publication
and uh yeah don't pay attention to that
that's how i kind of feel about when
they're like analysts for like stocks
and stuff and they raise or lower their
like their bull price which is their
highest targeted
like price that they expect to stop to
be and that in turn
raise or lowers the stock itself and i'm
like this is dumb as [ __ ]
everything's people are just buying and
selling based on what you said
if you didn't say anything then nothing
would have changed that is also part of
the whole thing too where someone
can get paid to write yeah yeah yeah
damn
crazy but yeah so this guy here the
second guy
he's a british man who accidentally
threw his hard drive and
yeah and so he has 7
500 bitcoins so he has more than the
other guy
[ __ ] seven thousand five hundred wait
what the [ __ ] well even though it went
back but damn
times let's say it's forty thousand at
the peak
oh i can't even it says three dot e
i can't even get the number 173 million
something million damn 270.
so what he did is ever since 2013
he's been trying to get his city to
allow him
to go looking at the landfill like go
digging through the land this is crazy
since 2013.
and so just offer them like three
percent or some [ __ ]
well how do you hire a team at that
point no listen he did
he hired the city 70 million dollars to
allow him to excavate the landfill site
and the city said
no because they can't even grant it like
it's just because of the environmental
uh
environmental impact that it would have
and there's like the environment that's
also 270 million dollars are you [ __ ]
kidding me
i'll donate carbon credits after i get
the money [ __ ] you
yeah well he how would he get it like
just look at trash one by one
that was environmentally bad about
looking at trash no not only that but
then
they said that it's not possible under
their licensing permit
and sounds like some shitty city [ __ ]
yeah but and also that the cost of
digging up the landfill
storing and treating the waste could run
into millions
of pounds and that's without any
guarantee of
of either finding it or it being in
working order so they might
they might if they would even allow this
there's like
so much impact that would cost a lot of
money have a lot of environmental
like damage and without the guarantee of
even getting the money they're like
who's gonna pay for it we don't find it
my sister just had her fence blow over
in her own backyard and she can't put up
another fence yet
because the city wanted her without
getting like a bunch of clothes permits
and all that stuff yeah so she like has
to keep her
dogs like inside kids inside everything
some laws are dumb huh
i forget that you're supposed to have
laws for these kinds of things because i
built when i built my fence
this past week my family was like oh is
that like a legal height and i was like
there are legal heights for fences i
just built mine
different cities how do they know like
do they just have city workers driving
around and they're like whoop
that wasn't there before i think so but
there's also so many [ __ ] out there
yeah that'll call it they'll build an
80-foot fence
and they'll put like double bird middle
fingers on it so i get why these laws
exist and [ __ ] this is so [ __ ]
annoying
but yeah so the exact exact percentage
that he offered the city was 25 percent
wow that's really good yeah and so he's
like that's up to 50 and they'll start
talking
that's a landfill man that's huge yeah
but he ended up looking at it too he was
just like you know it would be like on a
grid system based on a grid system
that there's a specific area that he
wants to try to dig
based off of like the trash that gets
picked up by his neighborhood it
probably gets dumped off that area
how is this guy sleeping though maybe he
needs to work with nasa
and they could get a satellite image
right you know in the movies i think you
can zoom in and zoom in and zoom in
you have to dance yeah so you can't you
don't have to like dig through it just
have a satellite [ __ ] zoom in like
crazy
that's good dude get [ __ ] jack bauer
to look through it with you
but by that point what's left for you
you've offered nasa 50
you give the [ __ ] city 35 and you're
just like god damn i'm down to three
percent
yeah because he said approximately 50
would be for investors who put up the
capital what's three percent of 270
million it might be worth it
also take it let's see and then he would
be left with the remaining twenty five
hundred that's crazy
yeah um it's still eight million dude
you know this cat
it's [ __ ] worth it but what if
somebody
found the hard drive it's not even in
the landfill some trash dude was like
i'll keep this i'll reformat it later
for my own computer build
hey free hard drive just gotta reformat
it first yeah it could be extra safe
yeah when he first discovered that his
drive hard drive was missing was when
bitcoin was
worth when his bitcoin was worth around
nine million
now it's two what was it 270 million you
said right yeah
i've said this many times just throw it
away bitcoin is gonna be worth two
hundred thousand dollars
some people say not over some people
think it's gonna be worth a million
dollars i think it will eventually i'm
saying i think the next to this at the
end of this next bull run
it'll be 200 000. so it's so funny
everyone's like i missed my shot with
bitcoin
that's what they said last time when it
hit like 10 000. there's only 20 million
of them ever period always
no my when i asked my mom i was like if
you find that cell phone if you're able
to get those four bitcoin that you have
are you going to sell or are you going
to get the money and she's like no i'm
going to wait till it hits a million
your mom's awesome
damn she knows all that [ __ ] she's smart
dude
your mom or your brother no my mom no my
brother that finds it
yeah they should have four million in
there yep and then
she's going all in on [ __ ] mary kay
that's stupid she's gonna be mary kay
herself
she'll finally get the rose gold mary
kay cadillac she'll be the one she's
gonna buy
[ __ ] herb alive dude she'll be at the
top of the pyramid that's always been
her plan
[Music]
smart
[Music]
you